good morning John that is if the world
still exists if the world does not exist
any more than bad morning John
very bad morn but assuming that the
world is not been destroyed by the kind
of crazy that would be hilarious if it
wasn't so freakin terrible let's see
what the world wants to know about North
Korea using our old friend Google
autocomplete
is North Korea going to bomb us that
depends first on who the US in question
is if US is me then no because their
missiles can't reach me which is nice
for me but if the US is everyone who's
not inside North Korea which I really
kind of feel like it should be then well
if you're in South Korea or Japan or or
even Guam they could they almost
certainly will not North Korea is a huge
fan of the crazy threat they've been
using them for over 50 years and though
these are kind of really extra crazy
it's pretty normal so why you may be
asking the uptick in the crazy a bunch
of reasons actually number one reason UN
sanctions against North Korea are
pissing them off especially because
China who is literally North Korea's
only Ally is supporting them to South
Korea has got a new president and every
time South Korea gets a new president
North Korea tests that president by
being crazy at 3:00 every year the u.s.
and South Korea do some joint military
exercises and there's always increases
the rhetoric that North Korea starts to
spew and finally number four no one
knows how North Korea works at all like
there's just nobody knows how the
internal political structure of
Pyongyang works and so there may be some
internal political reason for this and
we will never know is North Korea a
threat yes unfortunately first because
yeah they've got nuclear weapons and
they're probably the only state on earth
left that's crazy enough to use them but
more importantly we should all know that
North Korea's biggest threat is to its
own people who are malnourished the
average North Korean child is five
inches shorter than the average South
Korean child if you aren't declared to
be an enemy of the state and North Korea
which is surprisingly easy then you go
to a concentration camp what the
conditions are just terrible
but so does your entire family and any
children that you have they grow up and
live their entire lives in that
concentration camp and so do their
children three generations of people
there are people in those concentration
camps today because their grandparents
sympathized with South Korea during the
Korean War
what is North Korea communist no not
really I mean it says it right in the
title they're a democracy the death
kradic People's Republic of Korea and
they can vote actually there's only one
candidate on the ballot and if they
write someone in they can be declared an
enemy of the state which as previously
noted can be the very very bad thing so
yeah their system they're kind of an
absolute totalitarian multi-party
hereditary military dictatorship right
now on to the why does North Korea hate
the US well first because we supported
South Korea and the Korean War which
defines North Korea basically this is a
complicated story and I don't have time
to get into it but we remain South
Korea's strongest military ally and that
that is reason enough but second and
probably more importantly military
dictatorships need an enemy to rattle
their saber against and by rattling
their saber against the United States
the strongest power in the world they
can pretend to their citizens like they
are a global power which they are not
the people who live there have never
heard anything different and so did them
it does not seem absurd but while most
of the citizens of North Korea are
ignorant to everything that's going on
outside of the country I mean it's the
only place left on earth where you can't
buy a coat leaders of the country are
not we hope as idiotic as their rhetoric
makes them sound they know that if they
drop the bomb on another country we
would wipe them off the map it would be
terrible for everyone but we would do it
but these like tantrums for lack of a
better word have gotten them concessions
in the past and since everybody wants a
stable Asia and nobody wants a war in
Asia and Pyongyang is really
surprisingly unpredictable and I guess
it's better to give this screaming child
what they want them to have the entire
supermarket staring at you and feeling
really uncomfortable again if you keep
giving them what they want why would
they ever stop screaming John I'll see
you on Tuesday